yeah i
just for context i also had a company
which i eventually folded into
vaynermedia called grape story
that i started with jerome jar um
and uh around this space as well and
it's just crazy to watch how much
money is being poured into influencer
marketing you know even
even um a fun story for me is logan paul
who obviously went on built a huge
career the way logan paul started his
career
was my company grape story oh actually
vaynermedia and grape story
we had a we had virgin mobile as a
client
and we ran a campaign called discovering
the next vine
star like that was the marketing
campaign
and kids submitted and i was in my
office
there was three pictures and i got to
pick the finalist
and literally that's how i picked logan
paul and that's how his career started
he won a contest of a marketing campaign
that we did
which is crazy to think about now um
but this space for anybody here
obviously a lot of you are familiar with
it
here uh but for the ones that aren't
i don't think it's even remotely begun
and so you know obviously any questions
we can answer
thrilled to do it how do you see
influencer marketing on the b2b
segment i think it's very lucrative i
think the biggest thing though is a lot
of the personalities if you look around
are are focused more to b2c and can run
young but i mean this is where i think
influencer marketing has to be reframed
and understood as what it is which is
reputation
so if you're a lawyer who happens to be
really verse in blockchain
and you happen to be a good communicator
on video or you love to write
you going she or he going all in on
linkedin videos or written words
can literally become i mean can become
the way we
call it influencer you know so i i think
the b2b space is
very lucrative i think it plays out very
heavily in linkedin
if you want to go there and i think the
economics are even more interesting
than on the consumer side because it's
it can be very narrow and in our world
for a lot of us
five hundred thousand one hundred
thousand four hundred thousand three
million
we're all competing for consumer but if
you're in agriculture technology
and you're a thought leader because
you're putting out good content doesn't
have to be blowing up stuff for
high energy just thoughtful and smart if
you have
7 000 people following you in a very
small market
you could be making hundreds of
thousands of dollars
in speaking and branded content deals so
i think it's a very lucrative space how
do you see that like issue it like
uh branch saved in infuser marketing you
had this
quite non-event it's a non-event the
biggest companies in the world
you know this yeah some companies
well logan you know but you look at
logan paul right like and we we haven't
we never rep actually we did rep him for
six months um the whole thing with him
in japan and things of that nature
sure but like like the truth is my big
thing with brand safety and brands is
people forget
people don't like unless you do
something like murder
like it takes so much for it to actually
be an issue to your business
so i think most brands realize that
that can happen with an athlete i
promise you this athletes and movie
stars get themselves into
more trouble so far than any influencers
uh
and so there's always a risk when you do
some sort of endorsement deal
but as we know a one-off with him or her
is not necessarily you're the face
you're not the
like face of the brand i think when you
sign an
a-list celebrity or b-list athlete to be
the face of the brand
you feel a lot more brand safety issues
than
a one-off picture of like happy joe is
delicious
you know one time and then later i get a
dui
four years from now it's not going to be
necessarily what the brands worry about
how does it fly the other way around i
mean
and those who are b2c teen youtubers
bear with me but i mean if you're a teen
uh youtubers saying this is the best
mascara in the world
and this is marketing but if you are
let's say in in b2b
and you go with a certain brand
bad example clarion hotels whenever i
travel like
or if it's hey i'm at here at clarion
that because there are not that many
brands who want to work with you
so brand safety from from influencers
point of view
let's talk about that i mean from my
perspective
it's the balance of selling out
to me your audience is your number one
asset
so you know anytime you do something
like even when i ask to buy a pair of
sneakers or book which by comparison to
what i put out and what i'm asking for
in return
i always know that i'm cashing in chips
that i've changed the relationship at
that moment
and so when you're a personality and
you're putting out a product
you're giving up some equity you have to
decide
if the money you're getting is worth
what you know but i think if you're
authentic in that it's one thing that if
it's authentic
to like maybe i've never drank this
before but i'm okay endorsing it
that could be authentic it's not like i
have to drink this every day
i think where people get caught is when
they're whoring out something every week
and eventually the audience tunes them
out and then they've lost the asset that
they have
so i'm sure everybody can speak to that
here that's done it
everybody i promise you this every
influencer here thinks
about the deal right it's not like
the answer is not blindly yes ever
because you know that you're giving
something up for that money
and you and i mean i've never i have
been
an influencer since 2006 because of
youtube and twitter and i've never done
a single brand deal
i always built other businesses because
i just knew that that was
not where i wanted to cash in because i
knew the value of the end
audience attention on the flip side i
highly encourage it and think it's a
very good idea
but it's something i'm sure everybody
you know thinks about a lot
and you bring them deals right so for
him
just like for me and right for him and
the team they're like take it
take it take it in the right way it's
they obviously have to do a good job
they believed in it if they got to them
saying hey bro
take it they believe in it but it's
still up to him
her him him to really be thoughtful
because it's the only asset they have
it's the same thing where's the young
it's the algorithm
it's the same thing as the algorithm all
these influencers actually have
is the attention of the other person
it's the only asset they own
but this is why it's really really
important for influencers also build up
the whole business that it's not just
based on the ad
ads or brand deals you have to build up
new business i agree
i agree the problem is mostly please
i want to jump in the next oh you want
to ask
so let me just send this thought to and
this is why he's probably going to build
a successful business the problem is
most influencers not most
it's very common for somebody who's
creative and can be a personality
to not also be a phenomenal business
person
right but to your point i think where
you're going to see enormous growth is
in retail
i think the big next step for
influencers is selling [ __ ]
on shopify and amazon and other
platforms around the world
so i think one of the biggest thing
you'll him selling green hair dye
as like a legitimate business is
something i see
coming every day so i think selling
people are already doing it
logan paul's making tens of millions of
dollars on hoodies yeah exactly
yeah i believe in this quite a bit yeah
yeah yeah what are you thinking about uh
investing money on like uh
advertising in instagram for your
for influencers or for ads influencers
because all in
no no no no no no no no no believe it
a lot i'm an influencer yes so should i
like
put little bit money to like promote
i say they're beating like like beating
like little
amounts because now everybody in finland
is uh
like growing organic
so should we put starting putting money
to build your audience yeah yes audience
yes how much
as much as you can afford i believe in
it a lot
i'm spending tens of thousand dollars a
month months
and that's because because it's
underpriced
yeah it's gonna get more expensive yeah
maybe and that's in instagram
yes youtube as well instagram more than
youtube
youtube's more mature and is properly
priced
instagram i feel is underpriced both on
the
instagram ad products it's very under i
mean
yeah i mean everything in finland's
underpriced facebook
youtube instagram all of it's
underpriced because the big companies in
finland
don't believe the attention is there
which is crazy
and and the money's not because it's a
smaller market the money's not in there
from the entrepreneurs to the same level
that we see in other mature markets
so i mean for all of you i would put as
much as you can afford
back in because you're going to get paid
double over time
yeah what do you want
how about linkedin linkedin has a floor
linkedin's overpriced as an ad product
but
but valuable because of the nature of
the audience
so if linkedin had an ad product similar
to instagram facebook and google where
there was no floor
it started at one penny it would be the
place i'd spend the most money on the
most
because the value of the audience is so
business oriented so
money oriented so transaction oriented
the problem is they create a floor of
two dollars cpm
and a lot of that stuff doesn't work out
that's why facebook pre-k bridge
analytica
where you could market and a lot of you
who follow me heard me yell about this
every day
employees of they took that away
but that product was unbelievable
you could target people that worked at
any company you'd know who the [ __ ] they
were i mean
you could make the content for them are
you doing this when you are representing
like a vaynermedia like uh athletes
on the vaynersports side yeah we haven't
yet because
we're we're doing more organic yet do
you have social media stars
we don't no we only represent yourself
yeah well actually we have a division in
vaynermedia called vayner talent
where we do have people and we are
running ads for their content
yeah i this is something everybody
should be doing
and especially if you're like young and
making money pouring it back into
yourself is just a good idea
are you monetizing your facebook videos
yeah we just turned it on but it's it's
only because i'm learning it for
everybody like we just turned it on and
the only reason i turned it on is i just
want the data
you know i'm not excited about having a
mid role in my content on facebook
but i need to i need to use myself right
now to get the knowledge for all the
other stuff we're about to launch a
men's media company
i have purewow that i bought last year
so we're about to launch a men's
media brand and i need the i need the
information so that's the only reason
i'm doing it
i would have waited i waited on youtube
for years
you don't feel that facebook will
overtake youtube
oh i am a big believer in facebook i
think
i think that i don't think it's about
overtaking it
i think it's about both
for me the number one rule that
everybody here should think about
whether you're building a personal brand
or a business
is not to create friction for the
audience
so if they want to watch my vlog on
facebook i'm going to give it to them
if they want to watch it on youtube i'm
going to give it to them if they want to
listen to it on a podcast i'm going to
give it to them
i think the biggest mistake people here
make and when i say here i mean
[ __ ] everyone is they make content
for them and their behaviors not for
everybody else's
i think for example a lot of these video
stars
better start getting real serious about
audio because video is going to be on
decline
because video takes time that was
one of my questions on on b2b side
because a lot of the people
they just don't have they have their
work they have kids why not
so it's podcast what's your view on
podcast
big big i think audio is going to eat up
a lot of video
it's already happening it's just
right like even think about yourselves i
mean like think i you know one of the
things that in the limited time that my
eyes were open on the way to the hotel
this morning
like people are listening if they're
listening to music sure
but they're listening so much more to
podcasts than ever before
we all are and uh you know
it you know for me who's more
information based it works
when you're doing a highly visual skit
harder but i will remind everybody
technology brings us back to the past
the world ran on listening to radio
our great great grandparents they had
bigger imaginations they didn't have the
video
they listened to soap operas they
listened
and i do think that as crazy as it may
sound to watch
their content in audio form i don't
think it's as far-fetched as people
think and
definitely if you're informational no
doubt about it
have you done any influencer marketing
on podcasts
have i done any input what do you mean
by i want to make sure i understand
these things like dollars say
yes yes
have you done with it for any kind of
influencers with your projects with
mc or something so have we had
so i want to make sure i understand
we've done podcast advertising we do
influencer advertising
but when you say influencer on podcast
are you saying hire an influencer to do
the read
as the ad like how are you actually
asking
i think that's we haven't but i think
that's a viable option
if the show's audience matches an
influencer who has a lot of street cred
it'd be like an athlete reading an ad
during
during a sports show right um but we
haven't done that
how is it like monetization of podcasts
like what is the future like now it's
like
discount codes and stuff what is what is
the next i don't know i mean i think
i think there's a lot of ways there's
there's two ways you either do ads or
you integrate
natively into the show right so
two guys talking about esports
drinking happy joes and that's how it's
integrated talking about it once in a
while referencing it
making a joke about it you can integrate
it or it's just a live read in the
beginning in the middle or the end
so radio advertising is very black and
white
it's either ads or it's integrated
natively into the shell
how effective you see that how what how
effective was uh effective marketing
massively i think podcasts are grossly
underpriced
all right we gotta wrap up thanks guys